today i want to tell you about a really
fascinating line of blockchain
based software products that are being
developed by a project
called unfederal reserve we've actually
partnered with unfederal reserve to
create
this video and unfederal reserve has
been creating
really what's a suite of banking
products that are intended for
smaller u.s treasury chartered
banks and non-bank lenders looking for
more liquidity
without having to compromise on security
and without having to compromise
on compliance decentralized finance
defy this might sound intimidating
to some people in the market for this
type of software
but there are many advantages to merging
these types of banking solutions
with crypto if you read the unfederal
reserve white paper
you'll see that on federal reserve has
taken some of the most powerful elements
of crypto
and combined them with a really
well-designed regulatory framework
that delivers its middle market clients
basically like a swiss army knife
utility uh for b2b lending
for cash reporting for overnight lending
for borrowing and here's how it works
you create an account on their reserve
lending platform
from your desktop or from your phone and
through their
kyc onboarding you can quickly qualify
as a middle market lender and gain
access to the lending
marketplace once you're on there you can
easily track everything on your
dashboard which helps you summarize your
current cash position
uh and general network participant data
it's really simple to integrate your
balance sheet into the platform all of
your liquidity sources and uses
can be monitored in the platform it also
lets you
integrate your own existing accounting
financial and tax reporting systems
and they have excellent customer service
and support if you need help with
anything so in thinking about defy
in general basically any d5 protocol
is going to rely on democratized systems
so that any borrower can work with any
lender so the challenge
in the defy space then becomes the
engagement of more sophisticated
borrowers without the sophistication
individual lenders can't perform proper
risk-based
pricing differences in experience
can lead to arbitrage that can actually
hurt the whole community so this is one
of the things
that on federal reserve is really trying
to solve sophisticated borrowers
are really good at identifying when
there's a mispriced
opportunity unsophisticated borrowers on
the other hand
would be at the mercy of the more
experienced borrowing pros
which puts the whole lending industry at
risk so
unfederal reserve ensures that only
qualified
vetted parties have access to safe
legally compliant liquidity and because
of how on federal reserve is utilizing
blockchain technology here the
short-term lending
and the borrowing transactions get
settled almost instantaneously
middle market b2b lenders sometimes see
latency on payments they see
acceleration in other situations either
one can cost the lender
excess cash sits there while a cash
deficit might force
an emergency draw on a line of credit
and because
typical loan interest rates are
calculated based on
borrowing for weeks instead of hours
lenders
can incur a lot of unnecessary charges
when they're processing loans that are
this
short term which can be avoided another
cool thing about
unfederal reserve is their auction rate
bond platform this can be custom
tailored
to meet a client's specific workflows
which
uh can really do wonders for middle
market banks and non-bank lenders they
can feel confident
in lending to vetted third parties
directly and in
placing excess capital into the
marketplace
go check out unfederal reserve on their
website i'm providing a link underneath
the video and there you can read the
white paper you can read the light
paper a really helpful overview with
information about the company how the
products work as well as
links to their social platforms where
unfederal reserve
really does a good job of informing and
staying engaged the plan
for the second quarter of 2021
is the alpha testing and also launch of
the reverse
lending platform this quarter there will
also be
voting on their tier one exchange
listing
and some key relationships as well as
developing the treasurer's toolkit
which is their know your customer chain
the treasury management dashboards
and the maker taker protocols check out
on federal reserve's
blog on their medium page the march post
had some
very interesting updates including the
first product release the reserve
lending platform
and unfederal reserve has also started
a video tutorial project creating sort
of a how-to tutorial series on the
website
they're going to have a lot of excellent
new content on their youtube channel
they'll go into different topics
including
basics of crypto investing how unfederal
reserve works
where to find e-r-s-d-l how to attach
wallets so check out the youtube channel
really fascinating project
solving some very real existing problems
that are uh problematic in the space
it's a project
i'll be paying attention to and watching
i encourage anyone in my audience
to at least learn a little bit about it
and i want to thank on federal reserve
for partnering with us to create this
video as always
with any financial tools instruments
platforms anything that relates to money
of any kind
do all of your due diligence understand
what these platforms are and how they
work and speak to financial
professionals
before making decisions if that would be
useful
to someone in your position